top départ pour le grand quizz de
l'histoire de france 500 enfants ont
pris place dans la salle des batailles
du château de versailles transformée
aujourd'hui en clin géantes
l'idée c'est de montrer d'ailleurs à ces
jeunes que ce château il appartient à
tout le monde à tous les français que
tout le monde a le droit de faire
découvrir ce lieu qui est magnifique et
souvent quand on est dans un cadre aussi
magnifique on ne peut pas rester
indifférent et qu'il appartient à
l'histoire de france
et puis bien évidemment les sensibiliser
à cette histoire de france et c'est
important
un événement qui est l'occasion pour les
associations de quartier de donner un
objectif concret à leur travail sur la
culture avec les jeunes
on travaille aussi sur ce qu'on appelle
les valeurs de la république et donc
l'histoire fait partie de ces valeurs on
appartient à ce pays
et donc ces jeunes eux aussi ils y
appartiennent et donc bas l'histoire
c'est super important pour qu'ils
puissent se l'approprier
et être des acteurs aussi cette histoire
beaucoup de concentration pour se
remémorer le nom de l'hymne national ou
encore le nombre de rois qui ont vécu au
château les questions allaient de la
plus facile à la plus difficile pour que
les plus jeunes aussi puissent s'amuser
c'est très très très bien
on a passé un bon moment on a répondu
avant question est donc là on va y aller
au goûter de quoi laissé de bons
souvenirs
et pourquoi pas créer des vocations